Back in the second season of my
show,
I gave Los Angeles-based
realtor Sue Stanford
the idea of capitalizing
on the 50% of people
who believe in ghosts
by specializing in
the sale
of ghost-free homes.
- That's really a wild idea.
- So after giving
her marketing
a complete overhaul...
- Oh, my gosh.
That's amazing.
- I paired her up with
professional psychic Ron Bard
to help her detect
any ghosts that
might be lurking
in her properties.
- Definitely a change of energy.
You feel that, correct?
- Mm-hmm. Definitely.
I feel,
like, chills
coming down my spine.
- Right.
- Is it a ghost?
- No.
- What I never saw coming
was that Sue herself had
had intimate encounters
with spirits in her past.
- It's like--you know
what an incubus is?
It's a ghost that will have sex
with someone until they die.
- Wow. That's like
what I experienced
when I was in Switzerland.
- What happened
in Switzerland?
- When I was being choked?
- You were being choked
in Switzerland?
- Yeah, I--
- We were just talking
about that.
- What?
- Yeah, uh, earlier--
- Choked by what?
- By an entity like that.
I felt like
I was being picked--
- Wait, a ghost choked you
in Switzerland?
- Yes.
- Wow.
The filming of
the ghost realtor episode
turned out to be an intense
personal experience for Sue.
- Come out!
Come out, evil spirits!
- [sobbing]
- Come out, evil spirits!
Demons messing up with
the vertebras in the neck.
Leave now.
- Uh...
- Leave now!
- Okay!
- Leave, leave! Leave!
- Stop it!
- Leave! Leave!
- But with
so many distractions,
it was hard to tell
at the time
what she really thought
of my idea.
Are you okay, Sue?
- Yeah. Actually, I'm fine.
I think I'm in--
feeling a little relief now.
It's amazing.
[sighs]
- It's been three years
since I rebranded Sue
as The Ghost Realtor,
and when I recently
checked out her website,
I was delighted
to discover that
she'd not only continued
to use my idea
in her real estate practice
but had gone as far
as teaming up
with Ron Bard the psychic
and a small-time
production company
to create a television pilot
for a "Ghost Realtor"
reality series
that she was pitching
around town.
- I feel kind of funny
in here.
This is--this is not good.
- We're putting salt
in the corners
to disperse the negative energ.
If this was my house,
I'd burn this shit down.
- I was so proud of how far
Sue had run with my idea.
How are you, Sue?
- But when I gave her a call
to schedule a follow-up,
she shared some sad news.
- Oh, I'm sorry, Sue.
But she told me she was now
working with a new psychic,
and she wanted me
to come meet him.
So at Sue's insistence,
I paid her a visit
at her home.
- I want you to meet--
- Hi.
- Hey, Nathan.
- Joshua.
- Good to meet you.
- Nathan, good to meet you.
- J-Joshua?
- Yes, sir.
- Good to meet you.
- So I'm what's known
as a psychic medium,
but I'm also clairsentient,
which means that I feel,
uh, my angels.
I'm also clairvoyant,
which means I can see.
I'm also clairaudient,
which is--most of the time,
I actually hear--
I hear voices.
and, uh, I also do
financial advising.
- Oh, okay.
- Uh, it's--utilizing
spirit with everything.
- Sue told me
she was still working hard
to get the "Ghost Realtor"
show off the ground,
and she even hoped that Ron
could still be a part of it.
- He probably can help us
from the other side, also.
- Yes, definitely.
- Mm-hmm.
- That's a great point.
- Yeah, it truly is.
- We call on Ron
when we need some help.
[chuckles]
- Definitely.
- So you can talk to Ron?
Even though he's gone,
you can still...
- Sure, and, you know,
I can do--I could try
communicating with Ron
right now,
if you all would like.
- Mm-hmm.
- Right now?
- Sure.
- Why not?
- So dear Mother-Father God,
how grateful am I
just for this...
vortex, for this space,
for this time.
Grateful am I just for
all of the angelic beings
that are in this home,
and as we evoke
the spirit of Ron,
we are grateful that
Sue, myself, and Nathan,
as a collective consciousness,
that we are open
and available.
Okay, go ahead.
- Go ahead?
- Do you want to ask
a question?
- Uh, for Ron?
- Yes.
- Um...
Did he enjoy his
experience, uh, on the show?
- Yes.
- Great. Um...
- Are there any more questions
that you--that you have?
- I guess, how does he feel
about you replacing him?
- Uh, he says it's good.
He says he knows--
he says
that I've got
a good heart. Um...
So he--he says it's good.
- That's good.
- Do you have any other
questions, Nathan?
- Um...
I know, on the show,
he mentioned
that he worked
on the O.J. trial.
- Uhh, worked on O.J.'s
defense team...
- You worked on O.J.'s case?
- Yeah.
- So do you think he's innocent?
- He was definitely innocent.
- O.J.
- Definitely.
- Now that he's...
on the other side,
does he have
any clearer info on,
maybe, who
the real killer was?
- He--he does,
uh, but I don't--
I'm not getting a name or
anything like that right now.
- He knows who the killer is?
- Yeah. They--yes.
- Was it O.J.?
- This is not coming from Ron.
This is coming from me,
and that answer is yes.
- But Ron's
not telling you that.
- Every time I present him
with that, he steps back.
- Who's telling you then?
- My own connection with--
with my own--
with my own spirit guides.
- Okay.
Cool.
- That's how it works.
- Bye, Sue.
- Bye, honey. You take care.
[gasps]
Oh, I got a little kiss.
- Yeah, of course.
- That's so sweet.
- Oh, you're welcome.
- Okay. Well,
thanks for coming by.
- It's only--only for women.
[laughter]
It was great to see that Sue
and her new psychic
got along so well,
and even though
it was sad that Ron had died,
I was happy he'd still be
able to guide them
from the other side.